how's it going great how you doing good
how does it feel to be out and about
we're on a red carpet we're in person
it's the movie awards
i'm excited i mean this is insane this
is literally my
my first big sort of event for a year
and a half
it's it's insane tell me about this
jacket
yeah i mean a little bit of dior you
know actually
getting back into semi-decent clothes is
one of the benefits of
everything opening up so tonight's a big
night for you
the trailer for snake guys is coming out
what is your message to
fans after that trailer drops damn it's
gonna
literally blow people away it is of a
different material that we've
we've seen so far and i think kicking
off the new gi joe universe like this
is the best way possible so i'm so
excited for everybody to see this
we were of course on set with you when
you were filming it
in the cold i mean what does it feel
like that this project is finally coming
out does it feel surreal it's it's been
a long time coming and
you know that's how it is with movies we
we take the time we we tr
make sure the story is right and
especially with gi joe we wanted to make
sure that the fans like the pre-existing
fans
would love it as much as the new fans so
i think we
definitely cheaper what was the most i
guess
challenging part about becoming this
character
transforming into him the training
process
i mean everybody would say the the
physicality of it like the
the stunts we had to do every single bit
of choreography but actually
for snake eyes it's the man inside
it's it's it's the thinking it's it's
the
issues that he has to deal with through
this journey which is the most
interesting part
what is i guess would you say the most
unique part about your take
on this character i know we don't have
the the shield on the entire time right
the mask on
um who knows i mean you have to wait out
wait and find out with your face
but no we um you know myself and robert
schwenke the director really sort of
knuckled down and
and try to draw the essence of what
people wanted from a snake eyes movie
um not only sort of the kick-ass ninjas
but
the heart you need to look at the eyes
of a man to really understand him and i
think up until this point we've only had
fragments of whose snake isaac is this
is definitely gonna create something
pretty special
i'm so excited i'm also so excited
because you've become a father recently
i have are you sleeping right now i mean
how's the baby girl going i'm on the
night shift
so uh oh yeah my wife gets to sleep she
still has to sort of
you know work a tremendous amount of
pump and everything but um
she's a great baby she like wakes up
maybe like four o'clock in the morning
it is early whenever you look at it what
what is the best part of fatherhood for
you right now
i think seeing like literally every
single day she changes
and something new comes out she looks at
you differently
she smiles and melts your heart in a way
has it brought you and your wife
closer together of course yeah i mean
it's either end of the spectrum
through covid you either like hate each
other coming out
or you're even more in love with them
you're more in love absolutely i love
that and then uh before i let you go
scarlett johansson is getting the
generation award tonight
why do you think she's such an icon i
mean she just the roles her choices
i think everybody's just been following
her career since she was so young and
to see her kind of make the brave
choices that you know a lot of people
are scared to so um full deserved and
and i think she's gonna play even
greater characters
crazy rich asians too is there an update
yeah next year
next year
um i was like what i
i i think it's being ridden i think that
they're definitely mulling away and uh
we all hope it's soon right
i hope but you know as much as i do all
right well thank you so much
you